I'm going to talk to you paired and so I
came up with some individual questions
for our little chat this morning
directed three short films uh is this
like a is there a plan of directing a
feature in in your future 100% you know
being able to to like work
with you know like this cannon of
directors Robert Rodriguez Tim Miller uh
Barry Jenkins all the way to Roland Emer
and you know now um Zack Snider as well
as all the incredible
independent directors Anna Lily amnor um
Mass Matas from Denmark it's like
really I'm sitting there studying you
know I'm watching everything they do
every decision they make um the way they
interact with the crew and then you know
I'm analyzing on set and then when I see
the finished product I'm analyzing that
to kind of cross reference the two
and and just take what I can you know
that was the reason um that I had the
urge to begin writing and directing so I
think it's inevitable like Thanos I
think it's it's like I think it is
inevitable but it's going to be the
right piece I sense it will be something
London orientated my community
orientated and um you know I'm I'm I'm
I've got a crew list of people that I've
work with that I really respect and so
um I'm really excited to to transition
into that however I really feel like
especially now and after Noble and I
think you'll see it in the Extended Cut
I feel like this is like the deepest
I've gone as an actor and I feel like
it's kind of day Zero you know so like I
do feel like I've still got two decades
worth of you know minimum two decades
worth of like acting to grow like I'm
really interested to see where I am in a
decade and and 20 years as an actor you
know so it's not like in 2 three years I
want to transition into directing I want
to do the two of them as well as well as
like producing and and being a part of
cool and and and stuff I find
interesting and kind of vouching for The
Underdogs and pulling cool stories and
using the position that I've built up
through my acting career to kind of get
stuff greenlit and do weird geeky
underground you have played a
number of villains in your career um and
I'm curious what do you think it is
about your face the directors say
villain yeah I've got a resting villain
face a it I'm joking around by the way
but but you're you're good at a Villain
Like I know I know I I think like
definitely my bone structure lends
itself to a villain you know or or to uh
even when I play Heroes it's kind of
like anti-heroes or like Heroes that are
tainted or whatever um so yeah I feel
like um I feel like there's that side of
it the aesthetic side but the other side
is like I really enjoy it like I really
enjoy it I I and I think people can see
that on camera that I'm having a a great
old time you know and I also understand
like I'm not an actor that goes in there
like thinking about me and everything
evolves around me I understand that like
a character is is like like nature like
it can't exist in a vacuum like exists
compared to everything else so I
understand my position in the story and
what the screen WR and what the director
wants from me and how I serve the story
and so I think I think um
[Music]
I think that's one of the reasons that
I've been um been successful at being
antagonists yeah but I also just kind of
like exploring the dark side like you
know in real life like I'm just a big
teddy bear you know that's not that's
not true you're family has told me that
is absolutely not true I'm a big I'm a
big softy like proper and like you know
even I train martial arts and stuff like
I don't want no violence I don't I don't
want no problems but I love going into
the dark side it's like some Yun Shadow
work stuff where it's like like explore
the dark side and in a way that was like
what was great about this and what was
the worst thing about this is like we
shot for 153 days you know Deadpool was
55 days bro this is like insane length
of time to be deep underwater with this
Darkness you know with attacus Noble I
was
like I'm going to remove all Humanity
I'm going to remove all sense that you
could relate to him
you know uh-uh I want this guy to be
terrifying I want I want to see how far
I can push the envelope with like
savageness and coldness and harshness
and just like complete lack of empathy
and conscience you know and it was like
that came across on screen I think but
it was pretty horrible to kind of be
deep in that World for for for so long I
have to ask you what is it like when
you're part of a project that is
shooting for 153 days where you could go
a week where you're not filming I mean I
don't know how the schedule work worked
but I would imagine there's breaks so
how do you sort of stay focused in the
role you're doing but also do you see
what I mean like enjoy life but also the
marathon of making a movie like this or
two movies like this yeah I I don't like
days off I'm a proper weirdo like
that're like I don't even want the
weekends I just want to work like if I'm
especially if I'm away from home away
from my family I just want to knuckle
down I want to work all the time so time
off traditionally hasn't been good and
this why I don't really do TV I don't
one like a month off 5 weeks and then
come back in on this I didn't have so
much time off and when I got time off I
was grateful for it cuz I was exhausted
and you know we say time off but it's
like I'd still wake up you know 8:00
a.m. instead of 3:00 a.m. or whatever
8:00 a.m. I'm in the gym by 9:00 9:30
I'm there doing you know an hour and a
half of resistance work I'll come out of
there and go do a 3-hour stunt training
you know or if I haven't got stunt
training I'll go see um my friend Greg
won and go train myay Tha and his is um
uh garage dojo in Los VES you know and
I'll be out there back hitting pads
so then then I'm doing you know Zoom
sessions with my acting coach my mentor
Martin ledwith back in London so it's
like I'm
I'm I feel I feel f up every second of
the day because again it's like when I'm
away I'm like I'm here to work sometimes
my friends were like know Greg would be
like man like maybe you should like come
and enjoy LA and do stuff and I'm just
like n I'm here to work you know and it
was only once I finished I can kind of
like let that pressure valve off and you
know and all of that but really
like I was here for seven months I
didn't do anything bro like I didn't
have one drink I didn't go anywhere I
didn't go party I didn't go to
restaurants I didn't do anything it was
just knuckle down and work you know
there's a featurette that um an asset
that we
just put on to Instagram from Rebel Moon
and myself and when I see the interview
you Steve I'm like look I'm I'm a psych
I was a psychopath like I was so serious
and focused like watch it and you'll be
like damn Ed was like tightly bound it's
like where does atus Noble end and Ed
begin and of course like I'm not going
around hitting people with FEMA staffs
but like that kind of intensity it was
in me for that for that whole period and
um again it was good for screen but not
very nice to live with so we talked
about this um
I listen I'm a big fan of Zach's work
but um I always prefer the director's
cuts of everything that he's ever made
they for me they're the versions that I
that I'm going to rewatch again and
again so obviously I'm super happy that
the PG-13 exists but for your character
what would you say are the differences
between the PG-13 version and the
R-rated version is it a radically
different version is it can you sort of
talk about what you what audiences might
look forward to or see I mean I remember
while we were filming it thinking how
can any of this go into the PG-13 how
can my character exist in that world and
I was thinking like they've got they're
going to have trouble in the edit
because I pretty much you know we would
shoot for the R-rated scenes and then
sometimes he would say okay let's do
something for the PG-13 most of the time
I'd give them like one or two takes like
that like I was swearing like a sailor
and like pushing the envelope as far as
I could and in so many of the scenes I
can't mention them um on the record but
it was like I'm doing some dark
where I was like I can't believe we're
getting away with this I can't believe
that Zach is asking me to do this and
like I would suggest dark and he'd
turn it up to 11 you know I was like
this is crazy
so you get to know attacus Noble like I
can see that from from the PG-13 like
you you do really get a sense of the
character and his and how um cold and
ruthless he is but trust me R-rated
version the Extended Cut you're going to
really see who this man is and you're
going to be like he is a sick bosted I
got and I'm being so serious I really
cannot wait to see the the the the the
full Zack SN you know what I mean me too
so obviously part one is about to drop
what can you tease about part two
without giving you know spoiling
anything Steve it's all out War
it is crazy it's like the opening
there's so much it was like the opening
scene of Saving Private Ryan is like and
from my point of view with like the
stunts
like I do you know three or four times
as much as I do in the in part one Sofia
everyone we've got so much action you
know I look I look at the the the
background behind you velt and it's like
that's there's it kicks off dude it
really it goes off so
um from from a character point of view
not so much eus Noble but more from the
um the farmers and the rebels you do get
more backstory so you will get to know
them better but um it's almost like the
first film is kind of just setting up
for for how it kicks off in the second
part and
um I think it's going to be spectacular
yeah I really can't wait to see when it
when it all is done part one and part
two like the full for me the R-rated
versions of both I really can't wait to
see them me too man I can't wait people
to them I honestly feel like if anybody
Lika snowball or feels like we've done
good work with it in the PG-13 and you
ain't seen nothing yet really it's like
it's it's um H there's a lot more to
come